[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
hello and welcome to The Omen eSports
report I'm Rachel stringer and for some
reason my co-host - mr. mark Hatcher is
m.i.a
guys where is he ah there he is
practicing rocket League I see I mean
you found me
whales can I say you know I am prancing
rocket League Rachel because if I'm
honest of myself I haven't been
performing too strongly the rocket
League challenge so taking a few moments
just to get you know myself into the
rhythm for tonight that's all it is you
can say that again I what's the score
schools are relevant it doesn't matter
tonight it's a new day and in the
meantime I'm gonna take this time to say
let's take a look at the rest of the
show coming up on tonight's show we take
a look back at the months past action in
the eSports 60 we see who can aim under
pressure in the headshot challenge we
head to Twickenham Stadium to witness
the UK LC finals and we'll be joined on
the sofa by OD pixel Shiva and Freya
Spears
what you mean where oh yeah absolutely
now Nikhil Sam I'm ready so happy to
start the show yeah I think we should
let's do it let's start the show
well the styles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
by giving you the lowdown on the biggest
news stories in the world of eSports
this month you can start thank you
you can what honor it's so so kind of
you so kind of you well eSports 60 let's
get this one underway the fifth
installment in the gears franchise was
released a glowing reviews ESL announced
global csgo circuit with over five
million dollars in prize with pretty
impressive
apex news now as tears M when the
preseason Invitational g2 eSports be
fnatic in a thrilling SEC grand final
several claims the WCS full crown
[Music]
Maupin Dreamhack Montreal as the peat
sealed and look at Lee's
Championship Hockey League and Street
Fighter announces James appearing at the
Tokyo Olympics warmups make history as
they left their third major trophy in
know Vancouver titans and san francisco
shot set to go head-to-head for the o WL
grand final
well as enough stuff wasn't it I mean
what was your favorite part that I'm
gonna go the Olympics obviously network
connection yeah I guess 2020 the fact
that we've got I guess the closest we're
gonna come so far to having an eSports
tournament at the Olympics it kind of
ends on the same day the Olympic game
starts yeah it's pretty cool I'll give
you that yeah good pic I'll give you
that I love an underdog story so I'm
going for the peeps winning Dreamhack
Montreal taking down g2 what a
performance for them I'm sure they could
be talking about that for a long long
time absolutely right it's your time to
go up there okay I'm officer Control
Center where he loves to hang out for a
little bit anyway right taking
inspiration from last month's look at
the crazy amount of cash given away as a
prize money recently I asked the powers
that be to put together one of our
snazzy little videos to show off some
insane eSport stats I mean have a look
at this so the US population versus
fortnight players okay so 250 mil at
verses 3 to 7 mil for u.s. population
two thirds greater and then we have
optic gaming taking on the historic
Green Bay Packers their Twitter follow
object gaming is 1 million at more than
international prize pool versus dota 2 I
mean it kind of out have more money I
guess them a lot of these different
world series there 88 moon that is
greater of course but when we look
Djokovic is gonna be a little bit
annoyed maybe the dota 2 gamers are
earning more than him but FIFA their 791
in dollars I guess that still tops all
the price calls at the moment mark what
did you think of all those money being
thrown around I mean a lot of money of
course being thrown around in the world
of eSports and quite deservedly so for
some of those teams involved but
starting things off this week it's the
first for the control center as we look
at the world of Instagram for my first
story now this is the tweet that caught
my eye from Goldwater for an animation
production company who created these
amazing team intros for the o WL
playoffs to take a look
[Music]
[Music]
absolutely mind-blowing stuff they're
incredible intro videos and next up as
we mentioned a little bit earlier in the
eSports 60s trolleys managed to secure
their 3rd major trophy in a row last
weekend now you would have thought that
they would have been experienced at
lifting a trophy now by now excuse me
but this clip actually says otherwise
we're gonna see it roll here hopefully
if everything works nicely for us yes we
are and once you're gonna pause it just
after this part because you're gonna see
the trophy fall apart and then just a
look that I think everybody has had a
look on their face for whatever reason
you know that does happen it does happen
unfortunately unfortunat it's not the
first time this has actually happened
for Australis let's take a look at
something else that happened very
recently
[Music]
what's keeping it on that trophy in the
bottom left as well could you see a
couple of pieces just falling apart once
again and well actually gonna take a
little bit of a look at one of the
tweets that was sent a tweet of support
this was towards Australis from a glaive
saying welcome to the hashtag trophy
breakers club maybe not something you
want to be a part of but I'm fortunate
for Australis they seem to be making it
quite a regular occurrence now we come
to my favorite and this one is an
absolute beauty suite from league of
legends beloved Trevor quick shot Henry
says it all read out very quickly for
you here this might be one of the most
special things to see for me I'm very
fortunate to be able to do something I
love every day I'm even luckier to get a
chance to create content that really
means something to me
sandstorm is a personal favorite song I
got to be too rude for a day incredible
stuff there let's take exactly a look at
what he meant
[Music]
[Music]
amazing stuff they're right here to see
a little bit of a comparison between the
two here I'm not like professional with
this but I'm looking at it right now and
I'm thinking the editors I've done a
pretty impressive jobs it looks like a
little bit of a reimagine a ssin and I'm
sure that every single member of the
talent who was involved of course in
this recreation would have had one heck
of a time I mean look at it it's it's
pretty much perfect I'm not going to say
pretty much perfect
so next news of course last month we
gave you the news that oh the omen
challenge was headed your way and I
personally am super excited for the 1v1
action kicking off now we have more news
to bring you on that now as it's been
announced that the loading bar in
Brighton and Austin will be hosting
viewing parties so you can catch all of
the action alongside fellow fans now the
details on screen now is definitely
worth heading down as he'll have
giveaways as well as obviously all the
action to be watching everything was
gonna be up for grabs so you can see
plenty of stuff going down at the world
of social media but there's plenty going
on in social media let's take a look at
what's coming up on the show here's what
still to come on the show go to two
personalities OD pixel and Cheever sofa
we'll take a look at the dark side of
the International prize pool and team
mark takes on Team Rachael once again in
the rocket League Challenge and talking
of that rocket League challenge of
course it is time for the competition as
always if you want to get involved all
you have to do is guess who is gonna win
that rocket League challenge is it gonna
be team Marc or is it gonna be Team
Rachael all the transmissions are on the
screen right now you can get your chance
to win some great home owned by HP
goodies right but now it is my favorite
part of the show it is time to introduce
our amazing guests on today's show guys
ladies and gentlemen please welcome OD
pixel we have Freya Spears and we have
Cheever
hi guys
I need to sell the advanced oh well
thank you very much for joining us guys
you've been busy recently oh yeah yeah
Wow River downtime that long period
after the international finishes where
you know teams sort of take a break
all the casters and the panelists take a
break as well so I've been enjoying a
bit of time off well let's have a little
entry package into our first two guests
these two travel long world casting a
dota 2 and also travelled all the way
from Amsterdam to be here this evening
OD pixel and Sheva were supremely season
11 and now we are ready to head into the
draft of game number three so beefy
fancier got what they
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sourdough it
sourdough it on the OD pixel stream
there are little get old some of those
clip something they were beautifully
terrible we slash back casting on this
terrible laptop setup I mean that that's
not how old Aldo to events alike I do
assure you that was a one-off it was an
exciting event but Butler stream audio
was a little bit better than the
professional stream audio also the one
clip from my stream where I do a really
good play on Earthshaker
I mean whoever found that must have
spent hours sort of strolling through
all of it it's nice to see where you
guys came from to where you are now and
I guess let's talk about that the
International recently in Shanghai you
were both there I mean how amazing was
it to be part of this this is amazing
this is such a big tournament now as
well isn't it yeah it's a me it's always
obviously a big pleasure to be involved
in the International and yeah this one
is bigger than ever and in a totally
different venue no it's a totally
different location most of them have
been over sort of USA side now are in
Shanghai in China it was it was sort of
we didn't know what to expect if it was
gonna be sort of as grounds as before
but they really did knock it out the
park it was a great event and we had
some phenomenal dota 2 played there yeah
you've been around it for ages now was
it ti for that you kind of first kind of
host it out yes a CIT you're
interviewing at how is it developed
since you've been involved it's been
actually a really crazy write in terms
of how the international has progressed
and the whole DOTA dota2 scene as a
whole constantly valve has tried to
implement different things and at some
point we started getting majors we have
now have majors and minors and we're
heading into the third season of the
dota 2 pro circuit and that wasn't a
thing then so it's it's evolved and at
first it was only in Seattle after the
international moved to Seattle Vancouver
and now we went to Shanghai and next
year to Stockholm we're officially a
world tour isn't it yeah I mean we
talked about we know about how the prize
pool keeps going in one direction it's
become kind of VE tournament for people
to watch but it's not just that the
production level every single year just
seems to explode into this new level of
craziness how was it to experience that
well as a host it's getting easier and
easier because
you don't work as much because there's
so much content to show there's just
there's basically you're guiding people
from content to content obviously
there's still some time between and
opening ceremonies have been getting
crazier and crazier and and this one is
was had a little bit of tippet of
information of an announcement later on
than the International there's no hero
as announced and in the show you see
that there's four colors and there's
already you know there's there's green
and we have an earth spirit and there's
red we have an ember spirit and there's
blue we have a storm spirit and there
was purple and now we have a void spirit
so you know it's tough yeah it's a
little things let's just go on to it
guess the og they won back-to-back now
that they're both internationals did you
expect that see it coming I mean it was
no no I mean he obviously a lot of
people that maybe don't follow toads who
would say well they won last year right
so surely it's they're the kind of the
favourites to win it again I mean that
that wasn't the case because of the way
the whole season play down the fact that
straight after the previous Ti win they
sort of broke apart Anna the Kerry tape
took a break from the game so it didn't
look like they'd be back on on any sort
of top form once again but hey they were
they turned up and they absolutely
smashed it they rocked it through the
upper bracket and they knocked everyone
down and out and there's no surprise
that people like that nobody has done
that before everybody has nobody has
ever won an international twice and
everybody was always saying you know
that's because you kind of can because
the drive that you get for the first
time you can't really recreate that
but somehow og did it and it's not just
you know everybody has also gone into
the international love with the exact
same team often if that even if they do
it well they they change up one or two
players this is the exact same five
that's crazy that's true friendship
isn't it along with people for that long
to win to it the Nationals I think to be
fair you wouldn't that international
it's pretty easy to stay friends with
that is key to them winning back-to-back
the fact that they are such great
friends yeah if you would ask people as
like the power of friendship one through
and through I think the story of this
international of international 2019 for
me was obviously OG winning back-to-back
which is great but more so the fact that
they were able to do so very comfortably
and they were able to just play happily
you could see it on their faces they
smiled when they played you know there's
no pressure there and everybody else all
the favorites going into the tournament
they were struggling with that pressure
and I mean they had the professional
eSports psychologist that astral is also
used everyone be doing that now weren't
they getting a psychologist in building
activities yeah they have to if you
don't your we've already sort of seen
that there's a similar development
before right there's a lot of dough to
teams didn't have coaches they were
literally just five players who wanted
to play the game they didn't want to
listen to any sort of outside voices but
then sort of some one team got a coach
they started to have success no matter
what every we all need coaches and I
think you're gonna see that sort of
development with a lot of other
different sort of team members outside
of the five players in the booth and
especially as the money increases as
well you got the money like if you win
you've got you yeah you gotta pay all
the people that's a great point I mean I
was I was just gonna ask you quickly
about that before we go into anything
else because the international that
price will keeps rolling on and on and
getting bigger and bigger you have this
huge tournament every single year and
that's what causes me to watch and
someone you know the international has
become a calendar event for I think all
eSports fans and it's a great way of
getting people to watch eSports is what
I mean Freya I'm sure you caught up with
the international as well you kind of
get pulled in by the height exactly yeah
yeah we had it on in the face of office
it was a kind of highlight of the day
watching the international name I'm not
a DOTA fan I don't particularly watch
dota apart from the international it's
just such a spectacle and such an
incredible reason for everybody to come
together and watch the game I really
really enjoyed it
I mean then watch I went to the majors
for csgo for the same reason in watch
world's really good legends for the same
reason yeah exactly
I love that I was is Sarah an OG team
shirt walking around the tube today as
well which means it's kind of taking off
a bit so I was pretty impressed anyway I
was pretty staring at this guy's like
why is that girl looking at me weirdly
anyway there's so much more coming up on
the show tonight including a marker
myself going head to head in their
rocket League challenge you're not gonna
miss it still to come on tonight's show
we test our guests a
skills in the headshot challenge od
pixel breaks down and iconic clip from
TI apes revisit the UK LC final the
largest UK league of legends event of
the year and Freya spires joins us to
talk all things csgo
[Music]
okay right now it's time for the
headshot challenge and I'm loving it
even more this month because we'd have a
couple on the show as well so we've gone
and taken a Shiva here an OD pixel onto
this headshot China also gonna throw in
a little mr. and mrs. quiz just for fun
so it is it's kind of good on this check
it out this is the csgo headshot
challenge we love this part of the show
and today we've got OD pixel taking on
his other half actually shiva she's
backstage she has no idea what is gonna
happen up here you got 60 seconds on the
clock to get as many headshots as
possible this isn't particularly your
game is it no no I don't think I've
maybe got 10 hours and csgo it's so
that's pretty terrible pretty casual is
that more than Shiva definitely I think
it might be 10 more hours the Shiva has
okay well also because you are a couple
on the omen eSports report we thought
we'd do a mr. and mrs. style quiz with
you how do you go about that I'm ready
for our I hope I don't get questions
wrong and get in trouble later I hope
you don't either okay on your marks
let's start this who has the best taste
in music me who does the washing up the
dishwasher
alright Eva puts in the dishwasher who
asks for the first date as far as a
50/50 so much I'm sorry I'm really on
liner in real life I was real life or
life okay who is better at dota are you
definitely me
who makes the bed in the morning new
robot who takes long in the shower
definitely Shiva okay who is more
stubborn definitely me 10 seconds left
who has the worst morning breath
definitely me it's good do you have to
stop now I did say 10 seconds on the
clock stop right Tambor Shiva this is
Shiva and she's about to try and take on
Owen her other half I mean you've had a
little practice things weren't going so
good are you a little bit more confident
now no no great start there we go right
who has the best taste in music Owen who
does the washing-up I do
who else for the first date I guess I
did like that who is better at dota on
right got a half halfway and who makes
the bed in the morning
nobody does correcto thanks I'm getting
the shower I do
who is more stubborn I am okay time is
up stop put your gun down okay could be
worse I think it worse to practice so
you know it's an uphill climb who knows
where it could have ended up if I
continued playing it could have only
gone up guys right let each other know
what the scores are right now because I
believe you said dishwasher and shooter
said she does the washing yes because
lose the dishwasher that would be me so
you are on the same page really yeah
great
sorry I didn't want to cause domestic
there but I just had to check right
let's reveal the scores right now
they're gonna come up on this
leaderboard behind us Iblees have anyone
knocked Dan off the top spot no and you
guys yeah you are you didn't get you
well I bet Freight gonna be in you
anyway CS connects guy over there anyway
is anybody on now great school Chivo
you're not there just yet
you might be in a minute sixteen
I would be much that ibaka Feyerick and
you could only be well otherwise I would
be ousted from the community that I
meant that's a good point
one game you're the smart one if I don't
get involved by the way 26 magic number
hats off yeah the smartest people get 26
right now it's time to head over to the
breakdown board which these guys
actually filmed a little earlier and
they broke down a historic moment from
TI 8 welcome along everybody to my
favorite part of every single month show
is of course the breakdown at this time
we have got dota royalty alongside us we
have LED pixel and we're gonna be
talking through a play from last year's
international a huge moment that kind of
changed the tide of things plus you were
lucky enough to be commentating
absolutely yes Game four of best of five
grand finals og Ltd og down two to one
at the moment eleven million dollars go
in the way of first place but I want to
make sure that you you're able to grab
the victory in this best-of-five as
we'll see this sort of key fight
beginning already and it's already very
later on in the game you can see 61
minutes that's right you know get many
short games nowadays in the old dota 2
and when they go this long they are
pretty fantastic so we couldn't see
already at the top we've we've lost a
support not really too much to say about
that he's playing chan of hero this very
kind of useless at this stage the game
for the most part at least in the
teamfights he's just gonna fall over
like a piece of paper and if you want to
hold the pause here we've just seen og
try and push forward right there already
down one hero there 4 vs. 5 tops in
their mid he's just made the jump in to
go with a hex play where he's been able
to disable one of the heroes but he's
already been saved the counter play
coming in from lgd's tusk has put him in
the snowball and now because of that oh
gee they've lost the IO and now Thompson
as well he'll also go down so as you
want to pause it once more again here oh
jeez now lost three heroes they're down
to just the PL and the axe eligible
looking too good for them there's be
honest difficult for Heroes alive and
for forward them that are surrounding oh
jeez carry an ax he's the one that's
acceptable as he is all alone he needs
the backup to come in and bam there it
is
Samson he comes and he does die but the
commitment he made was able to grab
three members of LGD with the call
taunting them all and allowing Anna to
be able to turn and take them down and
stay alive and if you want to drop a
pause once more here we'll see this is
the big push they're able to then just
run it down mid with Anna he's the only
one left alive on og but he knows that
he can kind of get away with whatever he
wants to on the map there's two heroes
dead without buyback tusk is able to get
back into the game but he's sort of like
the support these heroes the bloodseeker
and brew at this stage of the game I'm
much more important they're out of the
game for over a hundred seconds and with
that that whole sort of that move that
og was able to pull off there they're
now at a 15 K lead they're able to then
go forward to close up the game and a
game that from 30 minutes to 60 minutes
they were at a net worth disadvantage
LGD they had this one in the bag
seemingly now there's a reason that I
said you know you were lucky enough to
be on commentary and I think maybe the
DOTA community is lucky enough to have
you on commentary because I think we can
hear a call that you made in the horse's
mouth how many want to do of course is
help you guys out at home and by having
someone like yourself here we look at
huge players like this what advice could
you give to play it's looking to improve
their game our hope that we've just seen
from this play I think my most part of
all levels of play for the people at
home is just did not give up as cliche
as it sounds when your teammates are
dying so many games that I've been in
you know I've played a few I think we're
about $7,000 in my bail you'll have
those players on your team but just give
up two people died on the team they're
already walking away from the teamfight
they're calling GG in the chat this
doesn't happen because these these guys
are professionals but for the most part
doesn't happen because og with they're
just two remaining players against I
believe four that were alive on LGD at
the time they saw the potential they
knew the power that these two heroes
could still have in them to turn the
fire around despite the numbers being
against them which doesn't happen very
often in the pub games because people
can be quick to give up but don't even
if your teammates are feeding slash
dying so don't give up stay focused and
stay out there in game chat for as long
as possible
exactly
exactly well that's gonna do it all from
the breakdown an absolute pleasure to
have someone like yourself breaking it
all down for us let's take a look at
what's coming up on the rest this show
still to come we look at the dark side
of the internationals huge price ball
Freya Spears joins us on the sofa team
mark and team Rachael face off in the
rocket League challenge and finally we
look at what to be excited for in the
month ahead we've got so much more to go
you excited about the rest the show I'm
looking forward to seeing what we're
going to still mark ok well let's keep
on this dota theme to start with and
we're gonna take a look at our first
feature of the show is gonna be a look
at how the International is costing
somewhat of a shadow over the tier to
see the International is in my very
biased opinion it's the biggest event in
eSports it continues to deliver some of
the best and most compelling storylines
across all of these sports
I mean og last year to me is the it's
one of the best cinderella stories I've
ever seen in any sport at the same time
the footprint that TI takes up relative
to the rest of the year
grows every year and that to me is a
problem for the past nine years dota 2
is the International has had the largest
price point eSports
but each year teams and players outside
the international struggle to earn
enough across the rest of the season
dota 2 and list and former economy
professor Nahas tells us his thoughts on
the long shadow cast over the dota 2 sea
[Music]
welcome to the International
TI this year represented the largest
portion of the total prize pool in dota
that TI has ever represented i believe
it the final numbers over three-quarters
of the total prize pool awarded for
playing dota this year was awarded at TI
and at the same time 80% of that was
awarded to the top four teams which is
again the steepest prize structure that
we've ever had a TIA
that's a problem the prize pool
distribution was not announced this year
until right before TI and it was pretty
obvious dat least to me that a lot of
the reason for that is that there was a
desire to eclipse fourtner not only in
the the over the 34 million versus 30
million but the idea that each member of
OT the winning team took home three
million dollars
[Music]
gaming
but the cost of that is you know how
many players how many teams know that
they're gonna eat and know that they're
going to be able to pay rent next month
playing professional dota and the answer
to me is is not many
I don't think T is acerra ly being the
the the mental focus or the storyline
focus or the convergence of the season
is a bad thing t I can be the brass ring
without being ridiculously
over-represented in terms of financial
rewards and I don't think that's a bad
thing a lot of the changes that I would
like to see in dota and in the pro scene
boil down to relatively less emphasis on
two weeks of the year and more on the
remaining 50 if you look at the total
amount of prize pool money award it
outside of tiata
that number is going down over time
that's that's a huge red flag to me I
worry a lot what happens next year when
the prize pools 25 million instead of 35
money what happens the year after that
you know right now we are in a position
where I worry very much if the TI
balloon starts to deflate what is going
to happen the rest of the scene
so a lot to think
obviously internationally we know for
his prestige for his huge importance to
the eSports scene and the prestige it
brings with it but as we all know
ecosystems are difficult when it comes
to designing for different eSports and
with the you know the growth of dota and
everything it's that time for that
conversation might be now what your
thoughts on what you just heard there
because obviously you know being
involved the international you guys
absolutely love love it for what it is
yeah I mean for me personally I'm sort
of on the other side of sort of white
allons allons is a super smart guy he
has a degree in big numbers you know he
is sort of just a fan and someone has
this roll up for the game I just love
the chaos I love the fact that each year
we don't know how big the prize was
gonna be we're it's this uncapped
crowdfunded amount of money that seems
to continuously grow in it it doesn't
make any sense right you know why why do
valve not limit it why do they not just
say hey let's make it a ten million
dollar tournament you know we'll keep
the rest you know it's like valve could
probably be making more money from this
than they are but they seemingly they
they just love to it's sort of run with
it just leave it open keep it growing by
insane amounts every year it's like 26
millions and 35 million people playing
any harder more people watching like not
as you know too many more people
watching it not the numbers don't make
sense but it draws people back every
single year and it always brings us back
to these discussions this sort of one
what is going on why do they just let
this and what and why is this a thing so
even though do you maybe agree or
disagree with what was said in that VT
there that the International waited till
after fortnight to release their prize
pool perhaps but to be honest valve is
not known for being timely with anything
so it's not really a surprise are there
that they are late on anything so sure
it could be reasoned but at the same
time do we care what the reason is I
don't know I think they have always been
having top-heavy prize pools and and in
every eSports scene every different game
has a different ecosystem that is
because there is no hundred percent
right way and especially you mean valve
has two big eSport titles under their
wing and they do things very differently
with csgo and dota2 and they're just
experimenting still even though you know
we've been around for a while but I
think that's a good
great opportunity to maybe ask your
opinion on this fair because obviously
counter-strike has a slightly different
scene in the way that it's structured
with the majors you don't have kind of
that one you know established event
which is all or nothing throughout the
year what do you think about the
international I mean I really like the
structure for dota 2 but I think the CS
I love that we can have different Tio's
having those majors and there's a real
emphasis on grassroots I think within
csgo any teo can put on an event which
is something that I really like and I
mean there's a lot of conversation so
now is the current issue for our teams
and players getting enough time so sort
of chill out and have a time with their
friends and family but I really like
that we have as many tournaments as
possible per year right I mean obviously
prize balls are another different thing
we haven't seen that kind of increase in
the csgo prize pool is with dota not
something that I would definitely like
to see coming in but the players at CES
they got sticker you're right yeah I
don't mean they do get a lot a lot of
revenue from that but yeah I think it's
it's it's great that there are different
ecosystems between different games right
that's what makes eSports so fun for me
is yeah I predominately work on csgo but
it's great to go to all the titles and
see how their scene works and all the
community isn't there maybe at some
point there's gonna be you know a golden
way to run all different eSports the
same way who knows I'll go be honest as
well I don't think I'd watch the
International if it didn't have that
huge number attached to it as well so I
guess someone like like you were saying
yourself ray like a little bit earlier
on is isn't you know hardcore dota2 fan
the reason I watch is because is the
biggest tournament in the world so then
that is very important for valve you
know valve in terms of sort of marketing
advertising they don't do it there's not
dota 2 adverts all over sort of your
streaming websites they they don't
advertise they get their advert is the
International they put everything into
it
they needed to be bigger and bigger
every year in it and it's been able to
do that and it's been able to draw
people in that is their advertising so I
am NOT saying that the dota 2 tier 2
scene is not struggling tier 2 3 or 3
because it kind of is but taking like
it's taking the International or cutting
their prize pool away
dividing it differently I don't think
that would solve anything in the long
run okay well it's certainly a
discussion that's gonna rage on for a
long time I'm sure no easy answer is a
we can see here but now moving from dota
over to League of Legends
one of the biggest UK eSports event of
the year took place at Twickenham a few
weeks ago as Excel took on fnatic in the
UK LC finals we were down there luckily
enough was quite nice of them to invite
us to see how it all went down here's
what happened this has been a very long
road to this point
[Music]
[Music]
so before we have the UK I'll see you
kill illegal edges a little bit scrappy
we had a lot of events kind of place too
low that we didn't have a formalized
endorsed scene it is a very special
event for us because we all worked so
hard we all partners in the team's over
the last 18 months Wallace to get to
this point as you may know the UK wasn't
a big different position in the past I
[Music]
think if you look at UK sports three or
four years ago it was a lot less known I
think this is probably the biggest
finals we've had so far sometimes of
like crowd and all the viewership as
well so it's deftly on the up they've
got announcing market exhales officers
are actually interconnected with our
relationship with Twickenham we hoped
that tricking them would become a
location for the UK eSports now that was
their hope as well already in the first
year to see the UK national
championships for league Legends which
is essentially the biggest eSport
- come here you know I ran a fast to be
in the final is it's pretty cool
you can see that everybody's buzzing and
interested and run loads of fans for
both the two teams turning up we're
building up to that grand final between
two of the premier UK eSports
organizations so it's going to be
massive for UK LT summer champions
phonetic writing teams were getting so
much support from everyone in the crowd
it wasn't like it was one-sided affair
everyone's cheering for fnatic
everyone's cheering for excel before we
didn't even have the live finals like we
just played online feels like a bit more
real you know they're actually excited
to watch it it's nice I mean this is a
really good like step into the direction
of how useful should be and how it will
grow in the future
I love events like this because they do
bring everyone together this is the
first time where you know it's solely
everyone is here for legal engines for
the UK seem to cheer on the teams they
want to see where
for a UK league of legends so many
things to take back from that but one
thing I want to talk about is how
Twickenham seems to be coming to MIT or
Harvard I noticed Freya and your social
media you've been hanging around the
Excel building a little bit recently
indeed I was at recommend yesterday yes
I London and we were just there a couple
months ago long ago yeah
no just last month yes oh I thought I'd
lost a month of my life but yes yeah
anyway I was at the Excel hey Tina
kindly gave us all the guided tour
around and it's a pretty impressive what
they've done with that space and they've
got a media room in there they've got
practice rooms they even toyed with the
idea of injecting some crowd sound into
the area so that they get prepared when
they go out right now it's time to
introduce our next guest from coming
runner-up in eSports competition to a
trip to Mexico to being a regular face
on the counter-strike world this is
fresh biz I'm free
what is up everybody explaining what I
meant you can run up in a competition so
that's a little bit like just to remind
you that you didn't basically you came
runner-up in a trip to go to Cancun but
tell us the story of what happened next
so sorry yeah face it was running a
competition of ESS season 4 because they
were running an event in Cancun which is
a pretty spectacular place to run these
spots there but there was no crowd there
so they wanted somebody to come along
and relay to the fans at home exactly
what was going on I didn't win she said
but I got contacted by the guys that
face it saying hey we'd really like to
work with you do you want to started
some interviews for us start doing some
voiceovers and of course I said yes and
then they gave me the opportunity to UM
stage host a TCS season 5 which was
incredible doubt probably well but one
of the highlights of my life really I
never expected to be able to do such a
crazy way help me I find their way into
eSports I'm sure we've all got different
stories but it seems to always be that
one moment if I have a chance that and
yeah yeah I love that yours was wasn't
it leaving boots to go out you leaving
the job at Boots the Chemist yeah and
talk about magic moments mine was
exactly that as well I had a moment
where I was commentating the longest
over two professional game ever it was a
game that went on for three and a half
hours back to bat non-stop action it was
like the first big game I cast with sort
of like big names and that's sort of
what people knew me from and then from
then it sort of just riding that magical
moment as you say it happens a lot in
sports it's taking sort of that a little
bit of luck a little bit of opportunity
and turning into correct yeah exactly I
mean it's always already got different
stories whatever but fray let's talk
about the face it major first yes yeah
so actually a year ago today we were
setting up for the first day of the
champion stage which was a super
exciting incredible at the SSE arena in
Wembley obviously where we host her a
lot of eSports championships
the prediction chicken was the highlight
on this he was absolutely spectacular I
know I said to you guys earlier and we
had video with him and chicken took a
big poop right all over the make up
which was not very nice but he was a
great staff that stays a little bit the
booze you kick in there get his makeup
done but then he decided to kind of give
his true opinions maybe he was I wasn't
at this competition as well when you had
the most difficult person to interview
on multiple occasions yes so I think we
have a show matter where we've got a
load of a load of icons from the Cisco
scene together one of which was IRA
who's absolutely lovely that was his
first time he'd ever played on land
stage which you look back now to that
just year ago he's done such amazing
things since then but um yeah I made the
mistake of not getting up and
introducing myself in a saying don't be
nervous it's fine it's just cuff for the
cameras obviously it's a stage in front
of 10,000 people cause he's gonna be a
bit nervous yeah we made light of it and
I think he was a really good sport for
going along with it and yeah one more
Lancers is always difficult it's always
Dickens to difficult interviews to
jumping to a team that we saw in that VT
just there Australia mean we need to
talk about these guys the budget Berlin
major excuse me I went down recently and
Australia's have just been on this
incredible run recently tell us a little
bit about that well yet people were
mounting them coming into the Berlin
major because they haven't done much
between iron companies that made it
previously and the Berlin major but it's
strange to think that people without
them could you look at the man and he
looks incredible I mean I just I was
looking this
and at the face that major where they
faced Navi they need all 15 rounds in
the whole grand final which is insane
again the same when they face anything
Cutt beats and only nine they only lost
nine rounds to us today I think it's
mental they are mental team and we
should of course Australis sponsored by
the wonderful people I'm at HP so
they've got that on their side as well
maybe that's er the success is happening
lucky stars you more of a CES band now
you've had a little bit and go as well I
mean it was not more because of that no
change things a little bit like tell us
a little bit about the omen challenge
which is gonna be amazing it's happening
on Friday you're hosting it yes I'm very
excited I'm very lucky that they invited
me along
it's a 1v1 tournament which is what
every country strike fountain wants to
see fans
sorry players getting outside of the
comfort of their own team we've got a
Nico and rain from phase we've got
simple and electronic from Navi and of
course twice from Australia a very
special guest our wildcard picker I've
just been told not gonna give anything
away but I'm so excited to have him up
on stage and we've got our two amateurs
as well Hayden and Nick
we've been selected by Australia's head
coach Sonic by looking at some of their
players so there's a lot of money online
as $50,000 and I'm super excited to see
if any of the amateurs can take on the
pros imagine imagine they pull it off
well we do actually have a little video
here about the omen challenge we should
say just before it happens this video
contains some flashing imagery but we do
have some information about it here so
we'll take a look in the meantime 2019
of course we've got these the players
that you were just talking about here
who do you think he's gonna be the most
difficult one to beat in a 1v1 I think
just based on star power you can't count
out suitable I mean incredible within
Australia no no disrespect to him as a
team unit there are making bit simple
math he's he's not human is he let's be
honest we all we've all seen what he can
do on a mouse and keyboard and it's it's
to be honest it's not fair I'll make it
more fairer that's gonna be great can't
wait to see that but let's now have a
new look at the rocket League challenge
basic this is a must-win game for you
I've needed to pull a performance out of
the bag yeah so mark he put up with
Shiva and I
paired up with Freya this is what
happened
gentlemen welcome along to the rocket
League challenge the score at the moment
is somehow or other three ones Rachel
it's happened I have a fantastic new
teammate who is full of confidence who's
not gonna let me down
shiva your face is not telling you those
three words I have scored three goals in
rocket League in total in my entire life
two of them were my own goal but I'm
really crying inside Rachel afraid yeah
and you should be really scared cuz a
minute ago she was changed a car she's
got now a fire coming out and back of it
so yeah should we do this just watch
this replay look at that face oh that
was actually good we have
come on in the field okay baby
absolutely genius I don't think it's
possible yes yes would either go my
restless
oh don't then get it in a pose he's
gonna be resmoke
[Laughter]
oh my god I've become some sort of get
out stay in the goal right chill I think
actually that should read winner team
she agree I agree I found myself a hero
Sheba cleaned up we win
thank you three to see you next time
[Applause]
to lose it so sorry how many girls did
you school 1 in this tango zero does
mean next month's show now is also
playful because if you win then it's 3
apiece which means sir don't you dare
what you do have interest but anyway you
know we've got so much more to talk
about let's take a look at the month end
in eSports coming up this month the most
unique event in the dota 2 calendar
returns for its second outing Midas mode
promises to be a wild ride
counter-strike returns the Big Apple
again this year for yet another
installment of the East Coast's biggest
eSports event Philadelphia hosts a 20-19
grand file between Vancouver Titans and
the San Francisco shop on September 29
no months is complete without a
dreamhack event and this month is none
other than Sweden's own Dreamhack Malmo
it's that time of year again with a very
best league of legends teams from around
the world come head-to-head before the
finals in November AGX brings with there
a plethora of new titles eSports and an
omen by hate P stands not to be missed
so much going on in the world of eSports
the next month but guys what have you
got coming on I afraid I know Friday's
pretty busy for you yes yeah I got the
only challenge from Friday which I'm
super excited about we've also just
kicked off ECS again for the online
season at face it so that's gonna be
building up to their finals later this
year and super excite to announce the
venue it's a busy business yeah guys how
about you - where did you saw the start
of that video - mode is there sort of
the next big thing on the dota 2
circuits coming up next week it's it's
without that it's gonna be the biggest
Thor 2 event outside of the
International it's you've got arch and
there's a lot of special things they're
gonna be happening it's gonna be
entirely different to any of us sort of
dota 2 event you've watched there's a
lot of surprises in store and they all
come of course from the fabulous mine of
Sur action slacks
guys I hope you're sold on that so what
these guys are up to
it's gonna be crazy and then we're gonna
go to Colorado for that one yes Colorado
as well a beautiful part of the world
well another thing that is beautiful is
of course announcing our competition
winner we thank every single person who
was involved who got involved and of
course correctly guessed that I'd win
Rachel because that's what happen they
should have been guessing like three I
left it just long enough so that I could
make the greatest comeback of all time
but I think it is time to announce on
competition
[Music]
nearly happens do you want to know you
can you know is that ladies and
gentlemen the winner of our competition
is is the end of tonight so guys thank
you so much for joining us all we have
time for tonight challenge just just one
more time so together anyway do one more
show left and that is next month it's
gonna be the biggest and best one yet so
please do join us in October for the
last set a show of the series there but
until then good night mark myself and
all the three guests here goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you